[Music]
I'm also here today to correct how the
magarri has portrayed me for their
political
purposes just like Daddy take no
responsibility for the mess he's created
instead just blame Maga now in addition
to his criminal tax charges he now as
Jonathan just said faces contempt of
congress for this flagrant skipping out
on his subpoena and then Grand standing
about it in front of the capital oh and
I must have missed it did Trump World
cause him to lie on his paperwork when
he bought that gun all those years ago
the enormous pressure that was put on by
Republicans from former president Trump
to the chair people of house committees
to demand that something more be done
that's not the way it's supposed to work
but that's the way it's worked so far
joining me now Missouri Senator Josh
Holly uh Senator um Hunter's lawyers are
claiming selective and vindictive um
prosecution of Hunter that's kind of
weak given all the facts that as
Jonathan Turley just laid out uh what's
your sense of what's Happening Here well
listen it is selective Justice when it
comes to Hunter Biden because here's the
truth Laura if he didn't have the last
name of Biden he'd be in prison already
everybody knows that what's driving this
is he is a rich liberal with a rich
powerful father and that is what has
protected him all of these years and if
if he were a workingclass guy who was
going to church on a Sunday what would
he get he'd have the FBI sitting in a
punix to him spying on him he'd have FBI
SWAT team's coming to his door to harass
him for his political views he'd be
getting hounded to death now because
he's powerful because he's Rich because
his daddy is president of the United
States he gets a different standard
that's wrong well Joe Biden is saying
that if he didn't run in
2020 none of this would be happening
like it which and of course they laugh
at Trump when Trump said the only reason
you're going after me is because I
didn't retire in
2020 and and they just discount that
when Trump says but now that's what
they're relying on that this is all just
political there's no there there or if
there is something it again it never
would rise to an impeachable offense or
uh or this type of prosecution well it
is political in this sense Laura it's
political for the bidens I mean hunter
Biden has made his living off of selling
access to his father clearly it is a
massive influence pedaling campaign
there's just no denying it and it's not
just one foreign interest it's multiple
foreign interests everybody from isma
the Ukraine China I mean the money that
has flowed through this family to Joe
Biden to other bidens and we have the
receipts you can see the money from the
foreign interest to Hunter and then from
Hunter to Joe and other family members I
mean it's undeniable it's there in black
and white so it's it's always been about
politics for them yeah the the source of
the income to me Congress hasn't paid
enough attention as to who and what was
sending this money to to Hunter Biden
and what they wanted for it to me that
is something that must be uncovered and
discussed clearly and laid out for the
public let them come to their
conclusions about what it all means yeah
absolutely I think that's absolutely
vital you're absolutely correct and
listen if if Hunter really had nothing
to hide he would have gone into the
deposition today and told the truth he
would have answered questions but he
doesn't want to answer questions from
anybody he doesn't want to answer
questions from the public certainly he
doesn't want to answer questions from
investigators he tried to get a
sweetheart plea deal from doj and would
have gotten by with it had the judge not
asked him tough questions I mean this is
a joke everybody knows that he is
getting treated with kid gloves
everybody knows that he's been selling
access to his father for years let's
have the truth finally and as you say
let's let this be done in public let the
American people see the facts and decide
for themselves Senator I think he should
be convicted just for that bad art um
just kidding good to see you thanks for
joining us thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else